hey everyone it's evan
this is a little bit of a different
video so what happened recently is i
miss one of my friend's birthday parties
he was having a birthday slash karaoke
party and i was sick as a dog i was on
antibiotics i didn't feel like going in
singing karaoke and i didn't want to
infect anybody else in the process so i
felt really bad that i missed his
birthday and the karaoke and
i made this video i hired somebody to
help me apologize to my friend louie and
wish him a happy birthday
and uh keep in mind that his favorite
song louie's favorite song is mustang
sally this is a warning okay the
following images may disturb you okay so
you have been warned
happy belated birthday louis you sexy
thing
since evan missed your birthday karaoke
party since he was sick he thought he
would bless you with the presence of mr
white chocolate
so i have to ask you evan are you ready
to do the chocolate dance with me
one year older one you're closer to
death soon you'll be losing your
freaking marbles like me
now i know it's a few days past your
birthday louis but we can always rub
chocolate syrup on each other and hit
the stage like this
mustang sally
guess you better slow your mustang down
oh lord
mustang sorry
happy belated birthday lewis and
apologies from evan for missing your
wonderful karaoke party i hope it was a
blast
i hope you enjoyed louie happy birthday
for everybody watching i hope you're not
too offended or disturbed by the images
i did warn you
see you all soon believe